there will be a lot more radicalism
taught in schools if Joe Biden gets
elected president because Joe Biden this
guy appears on camera what once every
few days from the comfort of his living
room it could easily be edited it could
easily be be massaged so he doesn't put
his foot in his mouth and he still
manages to do it most recently by saying
that he wants as part of his campaign
platform he wants the Islamic faith to
be taught in schools look one of the
things I think is important I wish I
wish we taught more in our schools about
the Islamic faith I wish we talked about
all the great confessional face it's one
of the great confessional face and what
people don't realize is one of my
application is theology don't realize is
that we we all come from the same root
here in terms of our fundamental basic
beliefs and I just want to thank you for
for giving me the opportunity for being
engaged for committing to action this
November you're doing what's been that's
that's never been done before you're
registered and turning out 1 million
Muslim voters this November there we go
I was wondering where did Joe Biden get
this recent love of Islam from where did
this since since when is Joe Biden
trying to set up madrasahs all over the
country oh it's because he's pandering
for votes as he always says so he says
we want to turn out a million Muslim
voters and he got a vote for me and I
want the Islamic faith taught in schools
consider the absurdity that we have come
to it is unconstitutional to teach the
Bible in schools which means it's
unconstitutional to teach Christianity
in schools can't teach Christianity
without reference to the Bible it's not
possible so as of the mid 20th century
when the Supreme Court decided to
legislate from the bench and and say
that it's unconstitutional to teach the
Bible in schools and yet it's now being
encouraged to teach miss Lyman schools
and this is the way it works I remember
even when I was in a high school and
middle school long long ago not that
long ago in New York we were taught much
more about Islam than we were about
Christianity we were taught much more
about Islamic history than we were about
Christian his
we were taught much more about the
Middle East than we were taught about
European history European history course
was an elective you had you had to
choose to take that but the world
history course which focused heavily on
Islam was required for two years this is
already happening it's not it's not
going to be Joe Biden who you know his
Joe Biden's pandering for votes that
that is going to get this across the
finish line there is a major double
standard here some people have said well
Michael they're just teaching about the
faith sure all right but they're not
teaching about the Christian faith cuz
you can't teach about a faith without
some reference to its source texts right
ciouds is that no Bible but yeah we
gotta read the hadith I don't think so
there's this double standard it's a
double standard being leveled on on how
we teach faith and religion how we
respond to our historical figures how we
build up statues and monuments even on
how we deal with conspiracy theories
there's a double standard anything the
right does is bad anything the left does
is good anything the left wants is good
I hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the Michael Noel's show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you
[Music]